known as the god of lightning hajim
kosimo has returned after 400 years of
ab silence to exact vengeance upon one
specific man this isn't any ordinary
bottom of the barrel mea level slop of a
character hajim Kimo was undoubtedly the
strongest man of his time and someone
kinjaku specifically sought out to be a
part of his calling game however zakuna
never existed in that time period and
Perfection was unattainable for hajim
now given the chance at Redemption it's
time to witness what it means to have
perfected the use of curse energy
turning and seen someone approaching him
at high speed now sakuna tells them that
he better not let them down flashing up
into the sky we see that without any
time for anyone to mourn or feel sorry
for Gojo's death the one that came in to
take his place against the king of
curses was no one other than the Thunder
God hajim Kimo hovering 203 M off the
ground kosimo himself is surprised when
he notices an object falling from even
further up at top that meteor sized
piece of ice was none other than the
Frozen queen herself getting surprised
herself though above Ur appeared a Cari
yelling out that she won't be going
anywhere not interested at all in taking
on the special grade sorcerer or
prepares her ice formation while
simultaneously hakari pulls up his hands
and activates his domain expansion even
though hakari was able to trap the ice
queen within his own domain the large
block of ice that she stood on kept
plummeting towards the earth below down
below of course was none other than the
king of curses who began extending his
hand towards the Now Melting Iceberg now
like a torrential ocean wave all of the
ice melt into water under an endothermic
reaction allowing the one-handed demon
to grab a certain object so remember
back to when Yu tried to show sakuna
love but absolutely failed well in the
end and in a similar way to my she used
her inate technique creation to use her
remaining curse energy to create a
specific item now with this dagger-like
item clinched firmly in the hand of the
one that she used to love it's revealed
that what yodu created was a replica of
an ancient item sakuna used to wield the
curs tool come a to this Tool's ability
seems to be one that allows the user to
control some form of electricity within
milliseconds of receiving the tool
sakuna launches a blast towards his
opponent which hilariously enough is
perfectly counted by the effects of
Kimo's own cursed energy speaking of now
Kashima asks the king of curses if he
earned the title of the strongest or was
he simply born with unbe able prowess
not actually having a clue himself
sakuna answers that he can't say much
but what he can say is that he was born
a cursed an unwanted Little Rich
stopping myself here for a moment cuz I
kind of want to point out a few things
this really makes me question if he was
born of a human and a cursed Spirit
possibly in a similar way to that of
choso or even Yuji depending on what
happened with him was he useless at
Birth like toi Ma and Mari and underwent
some like form of heavenly restruction
to greatly increases physical
capabilities then somehow reenter the
world of jiujitsu which like just
doesn't even make sense to me from this
though it's obvious that he was an
outcast from birth an unwanted Little
Rich for those curious about a major
part of what even Jutsu kaisen is about
it is all about teaching people what
love is it sounds soy and cringe as hell
but it's this underling part of the
story that now with a lot of the most
loved characters beginning to fall or
having fallen it's making itself even
more apparent to me sakuno fears death
because he is the strongest he has said
and he obviously thinks that you're
alone in death which also is just crazy
after what happened recently to Gojo we
saw that in jutu kaisen when you die you
are not alone if you're like loved you
were surrounded by all of your loved
ones be it in this world or the next
human or cursed Spirit Joo upon his
death instantly found his close friends
and so did Gojo with his entire year
from school even even freaking toi was
there I don't know know and people are
going to find it weird and it just kind
of obviously depends on how Yuji talk
noj it but the story began with Yugi
being taught what love is and it's
probably going to end with him teaching
sakuna that same thing either that or
it's going to be similar to you know mjo
but he finally gets to close it out this
time enough of me talking about love
though it's time for Kimo to attempt it
still in conversation he asks how sakuna
is able to connect with others how can
he love those beneath him without
knowing some kind of weakness to Kimo
it's something that he just can't
comprehend he was always surrounded by
the most feeble and pathetic people no
more than dirt in the eyes of curse
energy or pibbles of sand on a beach in
an attempt to understand him he pleads
with zakuna to Enlighten him as
strengthe at self Solitude or as the
endless search for greater power simply
a burden the strong have to bear alone
amused with just how greedy Kimo is for
asking about information on who he was
zakuna Chuckles but lets him know that
he'll teach him so be sure to give him
his best sh shot absolutely stoked with
the chance of a lifetime and something
he has personally wasted hundreds of
years for Kimo bursts forth jumping up
he slams his staff down at tops aona
only for him to comfortably block with
an electric burst before darting out of
striking range activating his onetime
use inate technique kashimir releases
his a over Mythic Beast Amber and
proceeds to Sock a shock sakuna with a
flurry of punches sending him sliding
back warping his body into an
otherworldly form Kimo directs his face
at his opponent and sends a blast of
electricity that explodes upon contact
with him joking that this form of his is
far too loud it's explained that Mythic
Beast Amber transforms Kimo's body into
something else I kind of think of it
like Eno's auspicious Beast technique
but instead of being an intermediary
kosimo literally becomes one of these
mythic beasts warping his body with
curse energy to resemble it in this
example the Amber version during the
time this ability is active kosimo can
use any phenomena that can be created by
electricity until his cursed energy runs
out I just want to mention that this
means it's possible Kimo can travel at
90% the speed of light or over 250,000
km per second at this you know point for
a limited amount of time using this
speed increase to his Advantage kosimo
takes Akuna somewhat by surprise and SE
a blast of Sonic electricity into the
ground directly below him instantly
following this Kimo throws a fat right
hook connecting with zuna's face and
sending him back leaving him flattened
upon the ground it's explained that by
activating the technique Kimo's agility
increases he can optimize the sound and
tune out incorrect noises to match
natural frequencies if any object is
sent at him It's Quickly vaporized due
to the electromagnetic waves flowing of
his body yet once this technique
concludes and because of how badly
Kimo's body has been exerted with curse
energy he will crumble to dust and die
using an effect of his own curse energy
and having placed a positive charge on
TOA when he C him Kimo releases the
negative one and sends a current of
electricity that instantaneously
connects with the king of curses already
weakened body so apart from a reverse
curse technique zakuna actually has a
method of restoring his original body
one that he isn't able to abuse and can
only use a singular time a certain
method that he' been intentionally
waiting to use since the beginning this
method was like the other members of the
King game resuming his transformation
through means of
incarnation activating his x-ray vision
kosimo is able to analyze the slowly
approaching demon without a doubt what
stood in front of him was Perfection
when it comes to like just how broken
sakuna actually is everyone needs to
realize that the reason he his extra
body parts and possibly even internal
organs is so that his hands remain
unhabited then while performing a chant
his lungs remain free and his heart
isn't burdened by the added effects all
of these extra body parts provide auno
with an immense advantage over anyone
else he may be physically deformed but
that doesn't matter or imped him in the
slightest instead as I've mentioned it
adds to his potential During the hean
period skuna was armed with both his
Incredible strength and the curse tools
known as the Supreme martial solution
and hetin hetin is supposedly the large
Trident like sta wheels that we've seen
in some like you know art and whatnot
whereas the kamu that yodu created is
most likely the recreation of the
Supreme martial solution with these
items zakuna annihilated the sun moon
and stars Squad and the five void
generals that served as guards to the
northern fujiwara Clan then on top of
that he decisively defeated the RB
Clan's Elite forces which included
Angels whatever the hell that means and
the dasi pacification Squad who
themselves were composed of sugara clan
members adly Blown Away with the unreal
achievement sakuno was able to complete
over his life kosimo can only fa over
how beautiful the Demon King's True Form
seems taking the offensive now Zuna
rushes at Kimo and manages to land a
double right handed body strike that
launches the sorcerer up into the sky
using the height to his Advantage now
kosimo shoots a blast of condensed
electricity directly at his foe
unconcerned sakuna with a second mouth
begins chanting while simultaneously
telling kosimo that he should probably
Dodge the strike out of nowhere
dismantle is sent forth and manages to
slice the palm of Kimo's improved Mythic
Beast form instantly the special grade
sorcerer realizes that this is the same
ability that was able to finish Gojo off
as it was a slash that cut the world
itself standing there absolutely jacked
out of his freaking mind sakuna jokes
that a fo once tried to teach him about
love yet she didn't even know what love
was and was also insanely lonely skun
explains that he understood what she was
trying to say however she just had the
wrong guy in his eyes she'd have more
luck preaching her love to someone like
Kimo or Gojo it's not that they didn't
know what love was it was just that they
were unable to understand it themselves
completely confused with like what he
was even trying to say kashim queries
him only for sakona to ask him a bold
question in itself he was strong right
powering up as if it's his last chance
because you know this is Kashima
unleashes waves of electricity that
shoot out in every direction undeterred
by the power increase sukuna catches
Kashima off guard and appears right
behind him grabbing his hands and
pummeling him with his two free ones
coughing up blood now sakuna slams him
onto the ground and throws a
demonstrably weaker sorcerer across a
decimated landscape of Shinjuku up his
hand in preparation for his next cursed
electricity blast kosimo is just left
stunned in front of him now and with
seemingly No Escape a bunch of world
slashing dismantles all overlapping to
form a net Rush forth like a torrential
wave of death all of a sudden and
flashing away to a place that probably
feels more like home than anything for
Kimo he hears someone speaking some wise
words behind him many of the world's
strongest Fighters must have challenged
him still with all of their strength
strength in spiritual dominance they
never cursed him in death in actuality
it's more that they just wanted
recognition from him then that would
give them an understanding of what they
are truly worth yet he butchered every
last one of them all while
simultaneously wondering how he was to
properly care for others in the eyes of
the wise sakuna if that isn't loving
kindness then what else could it even be
he knows that most people love them for
the strength they possess then they
respond to that love speaking up now and
wondering if sukun is satisfied Kashima
asks if that is the case then queries
why did he decide to divide his soul and
move through time as a cursed object
understanding this sakuna just tells him
that love is worthless through life he's
never needed anyone to satisfy him he
eats whenever he wants and plays with
whatever amuses him he lives life as it
befits his nature and if no one is able
to get that through their thick skulls
then that's their problem chuckling with
zuna's explanation k Asimo just asks if
it ever gets old but is quickly told
that it doesn't every human has a unique
and exuberant taste which makes
devouring them a perfect way to pass the
time until death arrives I want to point
out that unlike you know when Gojo died
Kimo wasn't surrounded by all of his
loved friends and family just auna I
wonder if that's like possibly because
he was a part of the culling game and
that's just the effects of it or
something I don't know kind of reminded
me of Jo goat's death for a moment which
just like how quickly he was living in
then in the shadow Realm I wish we got
to see more but this is you know like
realistic battlewise thinking that Kimo
was even going to last a third as long
as Gojo did is absolutely nuts either
way and back in reality now with aari's
domain shattering sakuna turns to see a
certain someone arriving on the
battlefield dropping in from the sky
both Yuji and hegar Ruma ready
themselves to face off against the
strongest entity in the history of jusu
Kaizen so this next battle is going to
be hella interesting no idea what Yuji
has in store for us with like this new
curse technique or whatever the hell it
is and sakuna is you know on the same
page wondering what the hell he's even
going to do here right now I don't want
to see higuma close out the series as
well just by sticking souna on death row
that just doesn't feel right to me
especially after the dude managed to get
around Gojo's Infinity I'm curious about
your thoughts on like everything down
below did you want to see more from Kimo
or you know were you happy with what you
got here or perhaps did you expect his
final technique to be a bit more potent
than what it like obviously was this
might just be a case of insanely strong
technique and the wrong person wrong
battle kind of like when we saw Gojo
display his powers for the second time
in shabuya which was utterly insane
compared to you know episode 7 where
Gojo just dunked on him like he was some
pathetic Cur Spirit if you want to see
more content just like this but for a
bunch of different series then make sure
to have that subscribe button we're
getting pretty close to 200,000 Subs now
which is dope as so it' be cool if we
could get there by Christmas either way
hit that like button if you have enjoyed
the video but for now it's been your
professional degenerate Deo and I will
see you all and a BS
bye